of what we're getting at you know the
the true zeitgeist of what we're getting
at when we ask the question
how do you find your own voice you know
how do you find your own
style oscar wilde said the answer is
simple be yourself
for everyone else is taken and that's
easier said
than done to be yourself because we're
impressionable beings and that's a good
thing that's how we learned you know
we are impressed upon we learn by being
impressed upon
people impress us we are impressionable
we are impacted by films by cinema by
archetypes by by by role models there
are
professors and thinkers and philosophers
and movie stars that
jolt us into awakening with their
effervescence you know they are so
magnetic they exude charisma we want to
be
like them i want to be like the lead
singer of nirvana oh my god to be
kurt cobain or to be tyler durden in
fight club or to be
patrick swayze bodhisattva bodhi and
point break these
archetypical mythic
male leads that leave such an impression
upon us
that speak
to the person we want to be right
and then the question becomes uh is
do we answer that call to be like them
no
we mustn't we must find our own voice
be yourself for everyone else is taken
so how do you do that right how do you
without becoming jaded or closed off how
do you allow yourself to be impressed to
be jolted
by others to be inspired by others
um and then respond
to that inspiration by summoning your
own
voice right how do you summon your own
voice
from
from the ashes of the obliteration that
comes when being impacted by the work of
other people right
because because good work good role
models good archetypes
people who inspire us annihilate us they
annihilate us and then
you know the phoenix that rises from the
ashes often wants to just reflect and
imitate that which has annihilated us i
want to be like my hero those that have
inspired me the most
those have slayed me with inspiration i
want to be like them but no you don't
you want to be like you for everyone
else is taken
so how do you do that well i can tell
you how i did it
i did it by getting out of my own way
because the part of me that wanted to be
like them was my
ego but not not necessarily like
a corrupted ego just an impressionable
ego
right i want to be cool i want to be
like jean-claude van damme i want to do
the kick that jean-claude van damme does
i want to have the six-pack that
rocky has you know i wish i could fight
like rocky but i can't
but i can fight like me you know i'm not
going to be tyler durden in fight club
i'm not going to have brad pitt's abs
i'm not going to be
as eloquent as alan de botton but i'll
be as eloquent as i can be
and the realization is that that can
only happen when you get out of your own
way
when you finally step aside you find out
who you are when you're not there
when you're not busy trying to be
someone you find out who you are
and and so that's what i would leave you
with that's how you find your own voice
you have to find a way
of slaying yourself you have to find a
way of getting out of your own way you
have to
allow yourself to die even temporarily
in order to be a vessel for something
else for
something grand for something beautiful
and for something
ultimately that's freed from the
trappings of your needy ego that wants
so
badly to become those that have inspired
us
forget it you know be yourself everyone
else
is taken